hi my name is joshua grochow i'm a
professor of computer science and
mathematics at the university of
colorado boulder
uh and in this talk i want to tell you
about my joint work with yeoming chao
from the university of technology in
sydney
uh on the complexity of isomorphism
problems for ten surge groups and
polynomials
tensor isomorphism completeness
so the problem of tensor isomorphism
arose from
many different areas it shows up in the
study of graph isomorphism as a key
obstacle to further progress on
graphimorphism in geometric complexity
theory
it's been proposed as a hard enough
problem for post-quantum cryptography
it shows up naturally in de-randomizing
symbolic determinant identity testing
classifying quantum entanglement
and machine learning where it shows up
in the signature tensor which is
actually a genuine tensor and not just a
multi-dimensional array that is often
referred to as a tensor in the machine
learning literature
so tensor isomorphism arises in many
different areas but it turns out that
its complexity had not really been
well studied previously so to help
motivate this i want to back up a little
bit and say why are we so interested in
graph isomorphism
and certainly it's a natural enough
question um
but one of the things that makes it
particularly appealing and particularly
widely applicable is that graphics
marxism is what's called universal
for isomorphism of discrete explicitly
given structures meaning
any kind of structure with rel on a
finite set with relations or
functions uh where i give you the
relation or function by writing down a
full
table of it um so partially ordered sets
carrier relations
algebraic structures like finite groups
or rings where i give you the full
multiplication table
hypergraphs uh simplicial complexes
uh all of these redu isomorphism for any
of these reduces to graph
morphism and we'll see we're starting to
develop a
a parallel notion for tensors
all right so with a little bit of that
motivation
in the background i now want to set the
stage for what are the objects we're
actually talking about
um so we'll talk about the isomorphism
problem for polynomials for tensors and
for groups
uh so for polynomials the input here is
two polynomials
uh f and g on say n variables and we ask
is there
an invertible linear transformation of
the variables that transforms
one polynomial into the other and here
how are the polynomials given
well let's just say for now that they're
given explicitly by a list of monomials
but
the the question is obviously
interesting in many different models
uh this problem showed up in many places
one of the interesting things is that if
you're interested in for example the
algebraic complexity of these
polynomials
um this notion of isomorphism preserves
circuit complexity in addition to many
other properties
um another sort of less obvious uh
interesting thing that shows up here is
that techniques that have been
used for polynomial equivalence for say
special cases of polynomial
equivalence um also turn out to be the
same techniques that can be used
in de-randomization or lower bounds for
algebraic circuits
um and so studying this problem is
connected to a lot of core problems in
complexity theory
so what do we know about the complexity
of this problem well if the polynomials
are say homogeneous of degree one
they're just linear polynomials
and you're asking about linear
transformations variables so this is
totally trivial
right as long as they're both non-zero
there's a linear transformation that
turns one to the other
in degree 2 these are now quadratic
forms but we're now talking about the
classification of quadratic forms which
over say finite fields or the reals or
the complex numbers
is also still easy but in degree
three or more uh it starts to get harder
so agarol and saxena in 2006 proved that
it was at least as hard as graph
isomorphism
and once we get to degree three or more
the best known algorithm that we have
is still essentially brute force uh
so we have over a finite field of order
q you get order
uh running time q to the n squared and
over real closed or algebraically close
fields you get two to the n squared
using quantifier elimination
but it's basically you're you're brute
forcing
over this matrix a that you're trying to
find
um and in the worst case that's the best
sweden in the average case
uh in recent joint work between myself
yeomin chow and gang tang and stax
stacks
this year we showed that in average case
you could get this down to q to the n
instead of q to the n squared but still
exponential
all right so that's our first problem
our second problem will be group
isomorphism and here we're going to work
in the model where the groups
are given to you not explicitly by a
multiplication table
but implicitly by generating sets of
n-by-n matrices say over a finite field
fp so i give you these two lists
of n-by-n matrices over fp and i ask
are the groups that they generate
isomorphic and here i mean isomorphic as
abstract groups so i give you the groups
by matrices
but i'm testing isomorphism just as
abstract groups for getting the fact
that they're given to you by
matrices and in our case we're actually
going to focus on a specific case of
this which is where these groups
are p groups meaning their order is
a power of the prime p of no potent
class
2 meaning that when you mod out by the
center what's left is a billion
so you can think of this as a promise
problem if you like but you can actually
check the promise
but the key thing here is like why these
groups well
uh p groups of no potent class 2 are
widely believed for
a variety of reasons to be the hardest
instances of group isomorphism
and while we don't have a formal
reduction from general group isomorphism
to this case said there's a
a variety of reasons uh to think that
these are the hardest cases of
progressive
system so uh
right we're gonna focus on on this case
where i give you these matrix tuples
and i promise you that they generate p
groups of no putin's class two and you
wanna decide
are the groups that they generate
isomorphic so now what's known about the
complexity of this problem
well again it's at least as hard as
graph isomorphism
this was originally shown uh in 81
by meckler um the reduction there uses
some complicated graph gadgets
uh and more recently just this past year
by
uh he and uh my co-author yeomin chao
and independently brochter and
schweitzer uh by much
sort of simpler more natural reductions
um but again the best known algorithm
here is still essentially brute force
which is
p to the m squared uh here it may be
less obvious why p to the m squared is
brute force
um but if you take the order of the
group as your
your running time parameter it's g to
the log g uh and so this brute forces
you're basically brute forcing over
generating sets of size log g
and trying all possible maps um and
again here in the average case
uh yinan li and uh my co-author yeomin
chao as well as brooks bank lee shao and
wilson
uh showed that this could be done in p
to the m time right so again
in the average case we have this
improvement this quadratic improvement
in the exponent
all right so that's the second problem
that we're going to focus on and then
the third one
uh our sort of starring player here is
is tensor isomorphism
and here tensors may be less familiar to
some people so
i want to talk for a minute about what
they are
in some sense they're just
multi-dimensional arrays of numbers
where
a one tensor a one-dimensional array is
a vector a two tensor is a matrix and a
three tensor is a three-dimensional
box of numbers the reason there's a star
here is that
not just any old box of numbers really
counts as a tensor
in the same way as not just any old box
of numbers counts as a matrix
you really want there to be some linear
or multi-linear algebra floating around
and that has to do with how these things
change under change of basis
um and how they can be combined with
other tensors
so in the case of one tensors and two
tensors that's like matrix vector
multiplication or matrix matrix
multiplication
um there are generalizations of those to
higher tensors and those are related to
how tensors change under change of basis
and that change of basis action is
exactly going to be
what our isomorphism question is so here
for the moment i'll just focus on uh
three tensors
um so i'm give you two three tensors
so they're like matrices but they have
three indices t sub
i j k and t prime sub i j k and i
ask are there invertible matrices a b
and c
such that when i multiply uh if i think
of
i as the rows j as the columns and
k as the depths the things coming out of
the screen
the idea is that a multiplies the rows
on the left
b multiplies the columns and c
uh takes linear combinations uh along
the depths here
so are there three invertible matrices a
b and c so that when i apply them in
that way i can transform
one of these tensors to the other and
here i want to give you a little bit of
a better feel
of what this problem looks like because
again it may be a little less familiar
so what happens when these are one
tensors
instead of three tensors well in that
case a one tensor is is just a vector
and my question is just are is there a
single invertible matrix a
such that a t is t prime where t and t
prime are now
vectors this is trivial right this
is true if and only if t and t prime are
either both zero or both non-zero
okay um now what about two tensors well
for two tensors these are matrices
and here what i'm allowing is i'm
allowing row operations by a
and column operations by b
and if you recall if you allow both row
and column operations you can always put
any matrix over any field into rank
normal form meaning
diagonalized with only ones and zeros on
the diagonal
so these are completely classified by
rink so two tensor isomorphism is just
matrix rank uh which again is you know
it's not totally trivial like it was for
one tensors but still pretty easy
but now we can ask for three tensors and
for three tensors
i want to get a little bit more into how
i think about this so if i have say an
n by m by p3 tensor i want to think of
this as a space of p matrices
uh corresponding to the slices of this
tensor so i'm going to slice the box
uh where each slice is say parallel to
the screen
and the k slice is thus a matrix so
sk if i call that the case slice that's
a matrix where the rows are indexed by i
the columns are indexed by j
and that's going to be sort of you know
k levels back the slice k levels back
here
and what does it mean if i'm now
thinking in terms of these slices which
are matrices which we're
more used to thinking about what does it
mean for two tensors to be isomorphic
well it means precisely that if i take
the span
if i take the span of the slices of t
prime that should be equal to taking the
slices
of t left multiplying
all of them by a the same a right
multiplying all of them by b
the same b and looking at the span of
those
and why does this span show up well okay
the left and right multiplication by a
and b is is sort of what we expect right
a acts on the rows b
acts on the columns and c what c is
doing here
is it's taking linear combinations of
the slices
right so visually that's what's
happening here and in terms of formulas
that's what's happening here
and this c is uh
sort of hidden in the use of the span
here
and the notation we'll use for this is
is our tensor t will be here a and b
on the left and right will be here and
we'll use a superscript c here just
because we need
something for the third third dimension
um so the nice thing about thinking
about these matrix spaces
is that uh the third direction is sort
of implicit
right uh when i when i have this span
here the way i've written it here there
is no c
right instead we replace that by taking
linear span but it's a linear span of a
set of matrices and so maybe we're
better about
thinking about that um and just to give
you an example
uh here are two two by two by two
tensors
right so i've given you uh here's one
tensor where this is the first slice
and then behind it is this slice
and here's another tensor where this is
the first slice and behind it is this
so this tensor in particular the ones
are on the body diagonal of the box if
you think about it that way um
and if you want a little challenge which
is not too hard but but serves as a nice
exercise
uh you can pause the video here for a
minute um
to try and figure out whether these
tensors are isomorphic
all right um one question here
that i'd like to put in people's minds
is uh if they're not isomorphic
how would you prove that what's a good
proof system for proving that they're
not isomorphic and can we talk about
proof complexity in this context
so let me walk you through this example
now
the idea here is well first of all i
didn't say what
what field i was talking about right
everything here is ones and zeros it
could have been any field
um but really i was kind of thinking
about over f2
it turns out they're not isomorphic over
f2 but they are isomorphic over f4
so if you would join a root of lambda
squared plus lambda plus one
okay um how do i know they're not
isomorphic over f2 well
kind of brute force right over f2 for
two by two by two tensors there just
aren't that many possibilities you can
try them all
um and you can convince yourself that
they're not isomorphic
but over f4 once i joined this
root of this quadratic let's see how
they're isomorphic
so first i'm going to conjugate both
slices of this so i'm left and right
multiplying
in this case by related matrices they
didn't have to be but in this case they
will
to diagonalize this matrix while fixing
this one right because notice this
slices the identity so conjugating here
should preserve this and i want to
diagonalize this
and to do that i needed the eigenvalues
of this matrix and that's why
i needed the the roots of this this is
just the characteristic polynomial of
this matrix here
okay um now i can rescale the first
slice
using my action of c in the third
direction right that lets me take linear
combinations but
one kind of linear combination is
rescale one of the slices and leave the
others alone
so i can rescale that first slice to get
it to look like this
i can now take linear combinations of
the two slices
to get uh some zeros and then i can
rescale
the second slice now to turn this into a
one
right and now after i do that this will
look like this okay so they are indeed
isomorphic at least over f4
not over f2 and in fact this argument
works
pretty much uh over any finite field
where i might need to take a quadratic
extension
um but the thing that i really needed
was i needed these two things to be
distinct roots of this polynomial
right of the characteristic polynomial
of this matrix because if they weren't
distinct
then these two slices would be linear
combinations of one another and there'd
be no way for me to
to get this out of them turns out in
characteristic five
uh this polynomial does not have
distinct roots it's a perfect square
and so these these uh two tensors
actually are isomorphic over any field
of order uh q squared
except uh in characteristic five
okay and we'll come back at the very end
to this question of what happens over
different fields
all right and now if you want to
challenge here are two three by three by
three tensors
uh you can play around with and see uh
are these isomorphic but that i won't
walk you through
all right so now that we've gotten a bit
of a feel for this problem let's come
back to
what do we know about the complexity
well we said one tensors and two tensors
are easy
you maybe started to get a sense that
three tensors are more complicated and
indeed
uh if you combine the previously
mentioned results of algorithms exceena
with a result last year that i had with
futonian sergey chuk
you get that three tensor isomorphism is
graph isomorphism hard
okay and again here the best known
algorithm is essentially brute force q
to the n squared okay
all right so these are our problems
they all sort of sit similarly they're
all at least as hard as graphitomorphism
for all of them the best-known algorithm
that we have
is essentially brute force and there's a
question of
can we relate them
um and then there's one more problem
that sneaks in here which is
uh equivalence of quantum states and so
here imagine that you have
two uh dequeuedit quantum states by
which i mean rather d
different particles each of which can
occupy a number of different states
and i have two such systems and i want
to know are there local operations are
there operations i can do
to each of the d particles to transform
one to the other
um it turns out that uh when you write
it down in coordinates this way this is
the same thing as just talking about
detents or isomorphism
and we know that as you increase d right
from one to two to three and so on
um that the problem doesn't get any
easier there's a very simple reduction
in that direction
but there's another question here of you
know as you start increasing d so
okay one two and three look different
right one was vectors two was matrices
three was
was now tensors gi hard and so on um
we can ask as we keep increasing d past
three
uh do these become equivalent at some
point
or do we get say an infinite hierarchy
that as you increase d
things get harder and harder okay
and it turns out that there are actually
dozens of other problems that sort of
have a similar flavor they occupy a
similar place in terms of complexity and
you can ask
are they equivalent
and one thing is you know these problems
look kind of similar
so i want to just give one example to
suggest why it's a little bit tricky to
relate them to one another
and this is let's go back to matrices
and think about
matrix conjugacy so axa inverse
versus matrix equivalence which is
ax b um
now okay both of these problems are in p
so of course there is a reduction
between them
but i only want to consider reductions
where i have some function
r that sends a matrix to a matrix and
i want to use this as my reduction so i
want a function r that sends matrices to
matrices in such a way that
um m1 and m2 are conjugate if and only
if
rm1 and rm2 uh are equivalent
and i claim there is no such reduction
why well the number of conjugate c
classes is essentially q
to the n let's say we're over f q and if
you like you can see this by looking at
rational normal form
but the number of equivalence classes is
just rank it's just
n right they're only n possible ranks or
n plus one
but asymptotically n and so there are
just
too few equivalence classes to have this
kind of reduction from conjugacy
but one of the results from our previous
paper with frutorian circatric
is that when you do matrix spaces
instead which we said is an equivalent
way to viewing tensors
there is a reduction from matrix space
conjugacy to matrix space equivalence
so this maybe starts to give you some
feeling of
you know there's something interesting
going on here
all right so now to our results
um this was kind of the state of the
world for
a bunch of these problems prior to our
paper so i'll just highlight a few
things here here is graph isomorphism
uh here's group isomorphism when it's
explicitly given by a table
here is group isomorphism for the kind
of groups we're talking about given by
matrices p groups of class two and
exponent p
um here's three tents or isomorphism
detents or isomorphism
isomorphism problems for algebras lee
algebras and so on
cubic forms uh rings
uh factoring is an interesting one
that's not an isomorphism problem but
nonetheless
uh there are some reductions from from
factoring to some of these isomorphism
problems
um and then some code equivalence
problems here
and so you know it's a very interesting
big mess
and uh setting the stage for our paper
um a couple years ago uh
in a joint paper with flutonia and
sergey trick we proved that
all three tensor equivalence problems
essentially reduced to three tensor
isomorphism so
uh however you wanna break up your three
tensors if you wanna have multiple three
tensors if you wanna say
i have you know a three tensor but i
wanna act by the same matrix a
in two of the directions on a different
matrix in the third direction or
a in one direction a inverse in another
direction and b in the third direction
whatever you want all of those things
reduce to three tensor isomorphism
uh and you can phrase this as saying
that three tensor isomorphism is
universal
for multi-linear algebraic structures of
degree or valence
three okay uh in the same way that graph
isomorphism is universal but here now
we're talking about
uh only you know things that are sort of
trilinear in some sense
okay so in this paper
uh what we prove with yeoming chao
is that in fact uh for any constant d
at least three d tensor isomorphism is
equivalent to three tensor isomorphism
that's our first result and our second
result
is complements the uh result mentioned
above
which is we give results from three
tensor isomorphism to all of these other
problems
right so we're giving reductions in the
opposite direction here
and so these are what we call ti
complete
by analogy with gi complete which is to
say these are
polynomial time equivalent to tensor
isomorphism
and because of our theorem a that dti is
equivalent to 3ti for any constant d
at least three uh we don't have to say
three ti complete we can just say ti
complete because
tensor isomorphism is tensor isomorphism
as soon as you get up to
dimension three okay
so this was the world sort of before our
paper
and everything in this box essentially
collapses
all of these things become ti complete
uh
after our paper so
uh and this box on the left here there
are some caveats here about
this only works over certain fields and
so on um
but uh the main message here is you know
there were lots of different problems
previously
and now there's essentially one
there is one interesting aside that i
want to highlight here
which is um you know we're sort of used
to this idea of
jumps and complexity from two to three
right so two set is in p
three set is np complete two coloring is
in p three coloring is np complete and
so on
um in this case two tensor isomorphism
is in p but three tensor isomorphism is
universal in some sense
but here it's not np complete right over
finite fields say it's in coam and so
it's not np complete unless the
polynomial higher
collapses so the question is
what's happening here right is there
some broader notion of universality
that explains all of these that that is
not just about np completeness
right but is somehow a more general
notion of universality
all right so now uh i briefly want to
give you
just a hint at what some of these
reductions look like
so uh for reducing detents or
isomorphism to three tensorimorphism
actually what we do is we reduce it to
algebra isomorphism and then we appeal
to the previous result that reduces
algebraic morphism to 3ti and the
algebra we're going to use is a quotient
of the path algebra of this graph
and actually many different graphs will
work but we use this one so
uh just quickly what does that mean you
have a generator for every arrow
in this graph and
two generators can multiply to something
non-zero if
one ends where the next begins
okay so for example x11 x21
is a non-zero element of this algebra
x21 times
x11 in the opposite order is zero
because those don't compose in the right
direction
or for example x11 times x
d1 those are also zero right because x11
ends here xd1 starts here and
we're going to quotient this path
algebra by
uh relations that encode
the d tensor that we started with
remember we started we're getting a
reduction from d
tensor isomorphism so we start with a
detent center okay
um to show that this particular
reduction works we really leverage the
theory of associated algebras so i
already mentioned the path algebras but
to do the proof we really need sort of
the whole theory jacobs and radicals the
wetterburn massage theorem and so on
and one of the interesting things that
we use as a sub-argument is a result
going back to gregoriav in 1981
uh which actually uses a very similar
algebra except
modding out by the square of the radical
uh which is essentially to say
in the path algebra you say any path of
length at least three
that product is automatically zero after
modding out by this
uh and gregorio showed that that's
equivalent to graphisomorphism
so we use that as a sub argument here to
say that this graph can be recovered
from our algebra
all right so that's just a hint at
what's happening
here and then i want to give you
uh one one little uh
example of what's happening in theorem b
so here the question is how do we reduce
tensor isomorphism to alternating matrix
space isometry so this is
the problem uh i give you
two lists of alternating or skew
symmetric matrices
x one up to x d and y one up to y d and
i ask is there an a
such that if i do axa transpose to all
of the x's
that the span of those is the same as
the span of the y's
right or in our tensor notation uh is
there an a
and a b such that a x a transpose to the
b
b in the third direction is equal to y
as three tensors
so we want to reduce general tensor
isomorphism to this and for this we do a
sort of gadget style reduction so we
start with a tensor a
which which need not be square in any
way and we want to produce a square
tensor where every slice is skew
symmetric and that has the properties we
need
and so we use this kind of gadget where
we're laying out these identity matrices
we have a and minus a transpose here
and these identity matrices tell us
something about the ranks
of the slices in sort of the three
directions and you really do have to
think about all three directions
uh in order to get this reduction to
work
okay so just to summarize uh tensor
isomorphism motivated from lots of
different areas
um turns out that it's equivalent to
lots and lots of different problems
as we show and that you get this sort of
universality
from uh as soon as you get up to three
tensors
right that the four tensor isomorphism
problem five tensor isomorphism those
are all equivalent to three tensors
all right and i just wanna end with some
open questions uh so one question is
we proved that detention is morphism
reduces to three ten sorry small system
but we'd really like the analog
of uh the previous result for all d that
you know if you take
a tuple of d tensors and you want some
of them
acted on in certain ways by the same
thing or different things or the inverse
of something
that those all reduce to detents or
isomorphism we expect that to be true
but it seems to be more complicated
for all of these in the worst case
getting any algorithm better than the
brute force q to the n squared
um and note that if you got q to the n
over say f q that would solve p group
isomorphism for p groups of class 2
in polynomial time in the order of the
group which is a major open question
in isomorphism testing
one thing you could ask is are random
instances hard for sat solvers
with an undergrad arthur pellegrino we
did some experiments and this seems to
be the case
but it would be nice to have an actual
proof
um you can also ask what happens over
different rings
so you know all of the results that i
talked about here was a reduction
between two tensor problems over the
same field
what about tensor isomorphism over
different fields and here it's sort of
interesting
even relating tensor isomorphism over
field f
to tensor isomorphism over an extension
field of f
it's not clear what happens but you can
also ask things about like what about
for example tense artimorphism over the
integers
right seems like a very interesting
question uh you might run into some
issues of say uncomputability there but
we don't know
you can also talk about what about other
groups instead of acting in the general
linear group
in all three directions uh what about
the special linear group
or the orthogonal group or the
symplectic group um
an sl is actually kind of interesting
you might think it's not a big deal it's
just scalars
that should be true but it turns out to
be a little tricky
um when you start getting to say
orthogonal or symplectic groups or other
groups
you know it really starts to look quite
different
or you could ask questions like what
about you know lattice isomorphism where
does that fit into things right so in
in lattice isomorphism you're allowed
the orthogonal group over the reals
for rigid rotations and the general
linear group over the integers for
change of basis in the lattice
right how does that fit into this kind
of picture
okay so there are lots of interesting
open questions here and then the final
thing i want to address is
why did we call this part one well it
turns out we have a part two
it's already present uh in the archive
version
of our paper and that has to do with
search
to decision reductions counting to
decision reductions and applications to
group isomorphism
uh so stay tuned for part two
right and that's all i wanted to say so
i will leave it there
thank you